hi
i appreciate you talking to me about
this i was very moved by it it's one of
those stories that's frustrating
heartbreaking made me want to scream
while i was watching it
um and correct me if i'm wrong but you
seem like someone who doesn't take an
acting job unless you're compelled to
and not because you're obligated to
so that being said why did you feel this
story was important to tell especially
knowing that it wouldn't be an easy
story to tell um
usually what happens is you read
something go is this is this
well written or i mean i'm just giving
you the macro now you know it's this
real written is or is this going to be
fun or is this interesting and
in my case a lot of times is did i have
i done this already or
or
or am i
a little bit frightened of being able to
to do it well you know
which can be a good motivator
um
so you break it down you go yeah this
this this here we go you know
kind of those are just a few of the
reasons why i might want to do something
um
and
i have a job
where
a lot of people aren't fortunate enough
to have a job where you get to do
something that you enjoy and also it
might
have an impact
on people might help somebody to put it
simply uh that's that's that's a great
that's a great thing to do something you
like and also
it ends up possibly helping some people
so
i'm fortunate
you've given a lot of great performances
playing a lot of different characters in
a variety of memorable projects where
does this guy fit in for you was he
challenging was he rewarding just in
helping to get this story out there
yeah um
i think it ranks pretty high actually
uh i haven't really thought about it you
know ranking him
but but now that you ask me that i would
say
it ranks pretty high uh i you know i
a lot of times i look at degree of
difficulty you know um
a long time ago i remember someone was
someone won a big word for something and
they were great
um
i and i'm
i'm not going to get specific about it
because frankly it's so long ago i can't
get that specifically about it but i
remember thinking yeah but i'd seen a
similar the issue the the this
there were two stories you know both
both films came out
and they were about the same thing one
was kind of
kind of disappeared because it didn't
have the
big names attached or the
publicity and i remember noticing how
good
the one was that never got any notice
and i remember thinking because the
degree of difficulty
like
like you know sometimes i guess i've
been giving credit for being good in
something i assume and i go yeah but
maybe it wasn't really that hard
because i always factor in the degree of
difficulty you know
so
so
you know everything's
relative
so i'd say the degree of difficulty
in this
not just the character but
when i had to do it how to do it how it
had to be scheduled how i had to
um
you know break it down and get the job
done and do it well and then move on to
another project and
you know
stayed focused all
you know during cove
by the way which i hadn't thought about
and this one everybody was quarantined
and you know
everybody you couldn't be near people uh
even on the set
i then i would rank this one up there
now that i think about it and just in
terms of the the person i just liked the
person you know that i played uh
um i'm not one of those people who
think i hear this a lot you have to
really love they end up having to find
something to like about the character i
don't necessarily believe in that if you
play a bad guy a horrible person just
play the horrible person
you know
go with it you know
just i don't have to go oh i like to
find something i like about him to do it
i i don't have a problem with you play a
horrible person
rick rock did some things that were not
very nice at all i didn't want to
sugarcoat it he also was a very very
hard worker
so you know i don't know i like this guy
i like phoenix
is it hard to get so invested in a story
that you can't that doesn't have a
resolution really it doesn't have a
happy ending these lives and these
families are still destroyed no matter
what happens
well you know that's a really good
question i would say the answer that'd
be yes but while making it i i don't i
don't know that i can think about that
you know
um
but yeah i mean that's that's
frustrating as hell but then you know
part of the
great thing about this series i think is
that
people get to
share the frustration you know
you know then there are activists you
know there are
activists now you know the uh
the voting issue right now is so
unbelievably worrying to me
it should be to everyone
you know this
basic basically voter suppression in 11
states now
based on
mostly race
let's be honest
um
that is so
upsetting to me that uh i don't think
people get how important that is i don't
think i don't think i think we think
about how important it is but there's no
there's no time to sleep on that one man
no time
well thank you for talking to me i mean
you're so though your performance is so
moving in this and i really appreciate
you talking to me well thanks rooney
appreciate it